Leonardo da Vinci's painting  "The Last
Supper" reminds us of that saying
"a picture is worth a thousand words."
Well, that's especially true when
it comes to remembering something.
Researchers at the University of of Waterloo in Canada
say that drawing is a powerful
influence on our memory
and can be especially useful for older adults
and even those with dementia.
Researchers had participants draw quick pictures --
4-second drawings -- of words in a list,
such as as "truck" and "pear."
Well the people who drew pictures
remembered them better
than when they wrote the word out multiple times.
Creating the drawings was
also more effective than imagining
the items or viewing pictures of the words.
Researchers also found that drawing
helps people remember even more complex words.
People who were given a minute to
draw an image of a spore were
more likely to remember it than people
who were asked to write out the definition.
Now, younger people were better
than older people at remembering
the words that they wrote out,
but there was no difference
between the two groups as far
as the words they had drawn.
Researchers asked 13 people
diagnosed with dementia
to either draw or write 60 words that were read aloud
The results showed a massive memory benefit
for words that had been drawn rather than written.
Now, in some cases the patient's drawings look like scribbles,
but it doesn't matter because
drawing ability has nothing to do
with memory performance.
Even those of us who can only draw stick figures
can get memory benefits and here's why:
Retaining new information
typically declines as we age
because of deterioration of critical
brain structures involved in memories,
such as the hippocampus and frontal
lobes.
However, visual spatial processing
regions of the brain involved
in representing images and pictures
remain mostly intact in normal aging.
And in dementia, drawing makes use of brain
regions that are still preserved,
and could help people
experiencing memory impairment.
These findings will likely lead to new
interventions and therapies
to help dementia patients and all of us
hold on to valuable memories